my goodness do you feel this energy that
I feel Yellow Jackets season two
premiere I mean the fans are going so
loud for you guys yeah it seems really
exciting a little overwhelming well I
mean I just got out of the car and
immediately went into like interviews
and photos but it seems really exciting
and great yes I hope your buddy Elijah
Wood is going to be here tonight I think
I think it is so cool to see the two of
you team up and from what I understand
people really sing your Praises you're a
wonderful person and you always like to
throw your friends names in the Hat when
it comes to Casting did you have
anything to do with getting him this job
I did not I was um I found out in the I
think it was a variety announcement
what was your reaction because I know
you have such a deep history together no
I was excited Elijah's amazing he's so
wonderful and kind and sweet and so
talented so yeah something I really
enjoy about this show is the physical
transformations of the characters and
you're such a striking brunette and to
see you on the show with the curly
blonde wig and the glasses what was your
reaction the first time you saw yourself
in full Misty mode well the first time
was the pilot and I actually had a gray
wig which they color corrected and
decided to make blonde
and I was thrilled and we did things to
make me look even worse in the pilot and
then they were like let's scale it back
so
um I was excited I mean I I really like
playing a character where I don't have
to be vain yeah you know we're so vain
in our daily lives that it's nice to
hide behind yeah so um I was thrilled
and I think it's so fun and I love the
way she dresses and I love not having to
really worry about any kind of Glamor is
sex aspects
speaking of Transformations I'd be
remiss if I didn't congratulate you on
all the huge success of Wednesday
[Music]
I I just have to ask it's a supernatural
show I know we said goodbye to Marilyn
at the end but are there conversations
about maybe you coming back I don't
think I'm allowed to say
okay could you say that the door is open
on your end I mean on my end the door is
open
is there anything you'd want to see her
do in season two God I don't know but I
mean she was so fun to play it's so
always so fun to play a villain so
someone who just has so much experience
with dealing with Fame and a surplus to
fame at a young age Jenna's really kind
of experiencing that now have the two of
you been in touch have you been able to
like you know be a mentor and a friend
to her no you know Jenna is so smart and
grounded and talented and capable I
think she doesn't need any help or my
condescension and giving her advice
yeah but but she's so capable that I
think she's gonna handle it all
amazingly well I can't wait to see
Yellow Jackets season three and
hopefully you in Wednesday season two
[Music]